YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do -
one two nine thirty one five seven three
one that is my texting community
platform doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there and also access
opportunity first looks in that
environment - and to 9:30 one five seven
three one join it now and now to the
video you've been wanting to watch we
have so much time we've so much time I
just wish that people had a better
relationship with time you got your
perspective
[Music]
I'm actually really excited I feel even
though we've been traveling we went to
we flew from New York to Dallas Dallas
to Monterrey Mexico Mexico to San Paulo
right oh no no Mexico Monterrey to
Mexico City Mexico City the same Palace
and Paulo to here now this and then we
run right back to the airport
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for having me Zillah how are you sure so
I think business and parenting have a
lot of similarities so when I hear those
kind of stories and I'm sure how many
people here are parents visually answer
so for all the hands I just want to you
know how challenging it is like you can
have common sense everywhere else but
when it's your kids it's hard to
maintain it but I believe that
self-esteem is the ultimate cure to
everything and I think most parents go
on defense when their kids are hurt
instead of offense so when their kids
are bullied they want to go fight the
school they want to go fight the parent
of the kid its defense for me as
somebody who was bullied because I was
you know I was a Soviet immigrant in
America and my childhood when the Soviet
Union was the enemy there was plenty of
[ __ ] I mean if you could even and I've
got goose bumps it was a very
challenging time but what my mom did was
she went insular it was offense it was
me and her in my own head hearing
nothing else by the time I was in high
school I couldn't hear anybody else
it didn't matter by the way throwing hot
so for me I think the thing you can do
is be into the about them not about the
people in Montreal or Toronto or Canada
it's not about that it's about yourself
inside your own head your
Southport and and you have compounded a
lot of parents here like most easy to
say but when their kids are making
you're right
it's but it's no different than working
out and eating healthy it's no different
than make content and put on all the
platforms the ants are simple pounding
into your kids head their own self-worth
not the opinions of others they'll be a
happy person or whole life the problem
is most parents are acting that way so
it's hard for them to give advice that
they don't even feel themselves but that
is why why do you think talk to me real
work here why okay
well you don't have to be in the content
she knows her crap yeah so what about
writing hey guys sorry to interrupt your
video I'm just giving you this call for
my number to let you know that you have
to join my text community to one two
nine three one five seven three one hit
me up with a text or what about audio
I'm doing so many people that don't have
confidence are very scared of the camera
but can do much much better writing or
recording audio this is so much time on
it in my talk I don't want people to be
like me that was not everybody is
ridiculously handsome and charismatic
you know what I mean though I don't want
people to be like me I want people to be
like me where they found their voice in
their media but for a lot of you in this
room that's right at me you know if
you're more introverted or insecure a
lot of writers are come from that
framework or I really like audio so keep
that in mind maybe this is the reality
of a lot of people here :
in a city where people don't think the
same way like story my time on it so
like it don't try to convince anybody
the number one mistake when you're
selling something new that most people
don't understand is people spend too
much time trying to convince them
instead of buying with a person that
already understands people make it a
noble mission instead of a business my
friend I've been right and early for the
last 20 years of my life I have spent
almost no time trying to convince
anybody I sometimes have a one-hour
meeting with the company fly from New
York to Chicago walk in sit down
start the presentation and ended after
10 minutes because I already know it's
over every minute that you spend trying
to convince somebody who's already know
is a minute that you're not spending
trying to find somebody that will say
yes
we business-to-business
I understand
so the question for you and everybody
here is what's big right because because
this is where people get caught it's so
simple being in a small town in
Argentina thinking you have to go to San
Paulo or you have to go to Buenos Aires
or you have to go to New York City it's
easy it's easy you're like that's a much
bigger place to go the question is it
comes down to what makes you happy
for me what makes me happy is to play
the game not the money not how big or
small I just want to play I've always
wanted to play I watched so many people
have a 1 million dollar business in a
small town in America or in the world
move to a bigger place do five million
and be very unhappy they were very happy
at 1 million in their small town they
went to a bigger town they do 10 million
and they're very unhappy my friend
Brazil it is time that we in the world
start making happiness what we go after
not more money
right for me when I hear a bigger I want
you to have a bigger [ __ ] smile on
your pretty face not make 280 thousand
more in the [ __ ] net revenue you
understand you have to decide that for
yourself I don't know you you have to
decide that for yourself
he said you biggest thing that you lose
when you say
yeah I mean brother site my biggest hope
for everybody is to not have regret
besides health help what you need I want
people to have happiness and as much
happiness and as little regret and you
know you're such a young man we have so
much time we've so much time I just wish
that people had a better relationship
with time there's so much more time and
so I'm glad that that hit you because
it's very real everything I do
everything is knowing that it's almost
impossible to be a human being 400
trillion to 1 that is the math the odds
of being the odds of being somebody in
here right now
is 400 trillion to one it's impossible
to be a human being and yet everybody
here is one and I don't want you to
waste it
why Baba no Westside
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Shopify's winning globally influencer
marketing to conversion of sales text
text I'm seeing incredible results in
e-commerce context
[Music]
I'm a closer today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good luck yeah I usually like it
on my right side cuz I'm writing but
this is my left side are you left the
most great creatives are for this this
is super neat really cool fun 20:19 see
ya
[Music]
Baban on a West Side